[Música]
[Aplausos]
educación qué piensas cuando escuchas
esa palabra no en su concepto sino en su
contexto
posiblemente pensase en tu escuela el
colegio maestras nuestros compañeros y
es lógico porque es el método de
enseñanza con el cual todos fuimos
educados en lo que respecta a lo
académico
sin embargo existen otras modalidades o
alternativas de educación
y en esta ocasión te quiero presentar
una de ellas que es justo holmes que es
formar académicamente a nuestros hijos
en casa lo que aprendemos en la escuela
en el colegio lo aprendemos en el
contexto del hogar
no sé si es primera vez que escuchas
sobre el house que hoy estoy
familiarizado con el tema en lo personal
yo crecí rodeada por familias que ama
homes con tanto los hijos como los
padres eran mis amigos mi hermana mayor
educo varios años a mis sobrinos en casa
así que para mí era algo normal en el
caso de mi esposo el al mudarse de una
ciudad a otra por trabajo
tuvo la oportunidad de vivir con una
familia y adivinen que ellos daban
escuela en casa así que antes de
casarnos nos pareció bien educar a
nuestros hijos bajo esta modalidad
nuestro deseo
era fomentar los principios y valores y
nuestra fe a nuestros hijos acompañado
de una educación de calidad
martin luther king junior dijo que la
inteligencia más carácter es la meta de
una verdadera educación y ese era
nuestro deseo poder darles conocimiento
desarrollo de destrezas
y los principios y valores que ganan ese
conocimiento
las razones por las cuales una familia
decide dar escuela en casa varían de un
hogar a otro tomaré como referencia a
eeuu
en una encuesta realizada por el
programa nacional de encuestas
de que es unas encuestas que van de casa
en casa e indican de que las familias
hayan eeuu optan por escuela en casa
porque les preocupa el ambiente en las
escuelas la seguridad las drogas la
influencia negativa de los padres
el 17 por ciento dice que no están
satisfechos con la calidad de educación
y el 16 por ciento tienen proveer una
instrucción religiosa a sus hijos pero a
esta lista y observando lo que sucede a
mi alrededor también vemos familias que
desean desarrollar el potencial o
talento de sus hijos como es en el caso
de natalia y sus hermanos ellos son
deportistas pero natalia también es
artista ella es una joven emprendedora
hace unos años el portal bastit puntocom
la catalogó como una de las artistas más
jóvenes del mundo así que ante nosotros
tenemos esta joven emprendedora con su
negocio pero que no sólo usa su talento
para esto sino que también recientemente
world vision honduras la nombró como
embajadora de world vision honduras para
los niños
también tenemos las familias que desean
facilitar la adecuación curricular a la
necesidad educativa de sus hijos no
todos aprendemos de la misma manera y en
el caso de jose andres de chico muy
inteligente determinado
a muy temprana edad fue diagnosticado
con difusión motora tipo psi él empezó
la escuela y luego pasó a home school y
la mamá pudo ver los beneficios que esto
representó en la vida de josé andrés ya
que la educación es la enseñanza es
personalizada
ella pudo adecuar el currículum a la
medida de jose andres tiene más tiempo
para ser niño para jugar actividades
extracurriculares
y tiene amigos de todas las edades y la
comunicación con sus padres ha mejorado
mucho
cuando se nos presenta un tema nuevo se
nos vienen preguntas y en educación y
preguntamos si es legal
que enseñan como lo enseñan
en la ley fundamental de educación de
nuestro país en el artículo 27 bajo
modalidades educativas tenemos educación
en casa
de ahí partimos lo mínimo que enseñamos
en la currícula nacional
y hoy en día existen muchas casas
editoras que preparan el material para
poder enseñarlo ejemplo de ellos tenemos
a fashion press
ishií ap kabul kingdom editorial y
muchos otros
y ellos te ofrecen le llaman curriculum
en caja porque nos vienen material del
maestro los libros de los niños de
trabajo libros de texto o nos tienen las
clases en vídeo y otros tienen su
plataforma en línea
también se han podido observar varios
enfoques en homes co por un lado tenemos
el estilo tradicional donde éste replica
el método de enseñanza en las escuelas
públicas o privadas
en el otro extremo tenemos lo que es
hans küng esta educación libre este tipo
de educación está guiada por los
intereses del estudiante donde ellos se
aprenden a través de la lectura de
libros que les interese a ellos a través
de viajes responsabilidades en el hogar
a través de mentores a través de
experiencia laboral y en medio tenemos
lo que es
el ecléctico que combina un poco de
estos dos enfoques deciden dar unas
clases de una forma más tradicional y
las otras de una forma más libre ahora
viene la pregunta y ahí justo ayer me la
hicieron como socialista es una pregunta
genuina si pensamos que los niños están
encerrados en casa que no ve la luz del
sol y que cuando los sacamos les hacen
así los pobres pero no
en un estudio un artículo publicado por
el profesor merlín de una universidad de
la florida
analizó varios estudios que se hicieron
en cuanto a la socialización de niños y
jóvenes en house cut y este estudio
indica de que son optimistas felices
satisfechos con su vida en los
adolescentes tienen un fuerte sentido de
responsabilidad social y aquellos que se
gradúan de la dejamos que van a la
universidad se involucran en las
actividades sociales y están abiertos a
nuevas experiencias
te preguntarás pero como entonces ahí es
donde podemos aprovechar lo que son las
extracurriculares llámese
deporte música arte e idiomas también
tenemos nuestra comunidad de home school
que hacemos productos o excursiones
vamos a empresas al correo a los
bomberos los paseos al aire libre
y tenemos también lo que es las
proyecciones sociales creo que esta
parte es bien importante el hecho de ya
esta iniciativa de la familia o unirnos
a alguien que ya lo esté haciendo
el poder crear una conciencia social en
los niños y jóvenes desde muy temprana
edad
y por último pero no menos importante la
familia el poder de nuestra relación con
nuestra familia extendida y nuestro
núcleo familiar
así que mettling concluye que una
perspectiva alarmista en cuanto a home
school no está basado en investigaciones
ahora pensemos como país a nivel macro
un escudo es una herramienta para llevar
la educación a áreas donde no hay
escuelas o estas solo llegan al sexto
grado y se puede ser creando las
estructuras para capacitar certificar
y proveer el material a estas
comunidades que les permita a jóvenes
niños y adultos comenzar y culminar su
educación básica
nelson mandela dijo que la educación es
el arma más poderosa para cambiar el
mundo y si eso es así
se imaginan lo que haría por honduras
recientemente no estuve hablando con
muchachos esta joven no tiene hijos y
hablando del tema pero ya como para
aterrizar
me dice bueno y usted porque me
recomendaría a holmes
yo fui miel sincera yo le dije no se lo
puedo recomendar
porque homes que es para todos los niños
no para todos los padres
y es importante entender
que antes de tomar esta decisión se
muestra consciente si podemos o debemos
tomar esa responsabilidad
ahora qué es lo que sí puedo hacer y lo
haré con mucho gusto si puedo informarte
si puedo hacer lo que hago en este
momento presentarte una alternativa para
construir la educación de tus hijos en
la medida de sus capacidades talentos y
pasiones muchas gracias
[Aplausos]